زعيم كوريا الشماليه يحضر جيشه لمواجهه
عسكريه غير مسبوقه مع امريكا نعم هو من
صرح بذلك فهل حانت ساعه صفر بينما قبرس
تعطي موافقتها لانشاء ممر بحري لدخول
المساعده الى القطاع والحكومه الفلسطينيه
ترفض مقترح امريكي وعبري جديد يقضي
بانسحاب قوات تلبيب من مناطق القطاع وخطه
عبريه لتحييد الفصائل ملثم القطاع يعود
ليعلن الحصيله ولبن يطلق اكثر من 80
صاروخا باتجاه الكيان تل ابيب تعلن مرحله
جديده من الحرب في القطاع صحف امريكيه
تكشف عن جريمه حرب ضد المدنيين في القطاع
وواشنطن تفرج عن الحزمه الاخيره المتاحه
من الدعم لكيف ليقولها لاحقا لقد نفد
رصيدكم وبوتن يكشف الستاره عن سلاح جديد
والناتو يحذر من
استخدامه ممر جديد لاجل
القطاع بينما تنتظر المساعدات في معبر رفح
على الحدود المصريه لتدخل الى القطاع
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه العبريه انها اعطت
قبرص موافقه مبدئيه على انشاء ممر بحري
لدخول المساعدات الانسانيه هناك اكد مجلس
الوزراء الفلسطيني رفضه لمقترح الممر
البحري بين قبرص والقطاع لما يحمل وفقه من
مخاطر على سكان القطاع واليكم المصدر حسمت
حكومه فلسطين موقفها مقترح الممر البحري
بين قبرص وغزه مرفوض وطالبت الحكومه
الفلسطينيه في المقابل بادخال المساعدات
عبر المعابر التي تصل الضفه الغربيه
بالقطع من جانبها كشفت صحيفه يسرائيل
هايوم العبريه عن خطه تعدها الحكومه
العبريه من اجل تحييد الفصائل من خلال
اقامه منطقه عازله عسكريه بمدينه رفح
الفلسطينيه على الحدود بين مصر والقطاع
فيما كشفت القناه ال3 العبريه عن مقترح
امريكي عبري جديد يقضي بانسحاب تلبيب من
المناطق السكنيه والسماح بعوده السكان الى
شمال القطاع وادخال مساعدات انسانيه
وادويه واشارت القناه الى ان الفصائل رفضت
المقترح العبري الذي تضمن صفقه تبادل
جديده قبل وقف اطلاق النار خلال ذلك وصلت
القوات العبريه عمليتها من شمال القطاع
مرورا بوسطه وصولا الى جنوبه فيما اعلن
المتحدث باسم الجيش العبري عن تنفيذ
عمليات مكثفه في حيي الدرج والتفاح شمالي
القطاع ليقول الوزير في مجلس الحرب العبري
بيني جانس ان جيش بلاده مستعد للمرحله
التاليه من القتال في القطاع متوعدا بان
يكون اقوى واعمق مما تتخيل له الفصائل
وميدانيا اعلنت الفصائل عن اسقاط طائره
استطلاعيه عبريه شمال القطاع ليخرج ملثم
الفصائل ابو عبيده ويؤكد تدمير
825 اليه عبريه منذ بدايه الهجوم على ذات
السياق قال تحقيق لصحيفه وول ستريت جورنال
الامريكيه ان غاره جويه عبريه على مخيم
جباليا في القطاع في في ال 31 من اكتوبر
الماضي قتلت احد قاده الفصائل لكنها ادت
الى مقتل عشرات المدنيين ايضا وذكر تحقيق
لوول ستريت جورنال ان الجيش العبري القى
على الاقل اثنتين من اكبر القنابل في
ترسانته بدلا من استخدام ذخائر اصغر حجما
لنات بالمصدر قال تحقيق لصحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال الامريكيه ان غاره جويه اسرائيليه
على مخيم جباليا في قطاع غزه في الدي من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي قتلت احد قاده
حماس لكنها ادت الى مقتل عشرات المدنيين
ايضا في التطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
افادت وسائل اعلام بان مقاومه لبنان اطلقت
اكثر من 80 صاروخا باتجاه مواقع وتجمعات
عبريه في مزارع شبعه والجليل الاعلى
والغربي خلال 24 ساعه لننتقل الى الشرق
الاسيوي حيث امر الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ اون الجيش والصناعه الدفاعيه
وقطاع الاسلحه النوويه بتسريع الاستعدادات
العسكريه لمجابهه خطوات المواجهه غير
المسبوقه التي تتخذها الولايات المتحده
بحسب
رويترز الاف 16 تصل
كياف بعد ان انهى الطيارون الاوكران
تدريباتهم في بريطانيا ها هي بعض المصادر
ترجح لمجله نيوز واك الامريكيه ان مقاتلات
اف 16 الامريكيه الصناع التي تعهدت بعض
الدول الغربيه بتقديمها لاوكرانيا قد وصلت
الى البلاد واضاف المصدر ان الدفعه الاولى
من الطائرات قد تكون وصلت الى اوكرانيا
بالفعل وها نحن نتصفح المصدر
[موسيقى]
امامكم من جانب اخر قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلانك ان الولايات
المتحده ستقدم ما يصل الى 250 مليون دولار
من الاسلحه والمعدات لكيا مطالبا الكونجرس
بالتصرف في اقرب في وقت ممكن فيما افادت
وكاله رايترز نقلا عن البيت الابيض ان
الاداره الامريكيه تعتزم تقديم مساعده
امريكيه عسكريه اضافيه لاوكرانيا بقيمه 20
مليون دولار يبدو ان ايام الدعم
بالمليارات قد ولت هنا اكد مندوب روسيا
الدائم لدى المنظمات الدوليه في فينا
ميخائيل اوليانوف ان الولايات المتحده هي
المستفيد الرئيسي من النزاع في اوكرانيا
بينما تتكبد الدول الاوروبيه خسائر جمه
بسببه وفق وكاله سبوتنيك ليخرج رئيس نظام
كيا فلاديمير زيلينسكي ويصرح على حسابه في
شبكه اكس ان اوكرانيا تلقت على مدار هذا
العام 34 حزبه من المساعدات العسكريه
بقيمه تزيد على 24 مليار دولار من
الولايات المتحده بينما اعتبرت ضابطه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه السابقه ريبيكا
كوفل ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وقع على
حكم الاعدام بحق اوكرانيا عبر سياسه دفعها
للانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي بحسب مجله
نيوزويك اما في المانيا ف اعلن ممثل وزاره
الماليه ان سلطات بلاده جمدت اعتبارا من
بدايه ديسمبر اصولا روسيه تقدر بنحو 4 فوا
مليار يورو وذلك بموجب نظام عقوبات
الاتحاد الاوروبي لتواصل الصحف الامريكيه
توضيح الوضع الاوكراني اكثر هنا صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز تؤكد انه لا ينبغي
لاوكرانيا ان تتخلى عن المفاوضات مع روسيا
بعد المحاولات الفاشله للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه للتقدم على الجبهه من جهته قال
المعلق العسكري الامريكي بيتر سوتشو في
مقاله نشرتها مجله ذا ناشونال انترست انه
يمكن اعتبار طائره الشبح الروسيه بدون
طيار اس 7 اختنك بي تهديدا فعليا للناتو
على الارض الاوكرانيه كشفت مجله فوربس ان
القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه والقوات
الداعمه لها في منطقه بلده كرنكي على
الضفه اليسرى لنهر النمبر فقدت 50 مركبه
مائيه في شهر ونصف لتعلن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان قواتها احبطت عددا من الهجمات
الاوكرانيه على عده محاور وكبدت القوات
المهاجمه خسائر كبيره في العتاد والسلاح
هذا واعلنت الوزاره الروسيه عن الحصيله
اليوميه بتدمير ثلاث طائرات حربيه
اوكرانيه من طراز سوء 25 ونحو
عسكريا
ch